où avez-vous trouvé cela dans une boîte des cassettes VHS que
les anciens propriétaires ont laissées au
sous-sol Kati Christy Je veux que vous vous
concentriez Je pense que la peur universelle la plus courante
est que vous êtes à la maison,
vous dormez la nuit et quelque chose
ne va pas  dans votre maison et je pense que cette
caméra peut voir des choses que vous ne pouvez pas voir
à l'œil nu il y a quelque chose
derrière la dimension fantôme est le dernier film
de la série Paranormal Activity de
cette série particulière et ce que vous pouvez
attendre de cette activité paranormale,
c'est qu'elle répond à tout  les questions ne sont pas une
coïncidence et je crois qu'elle fait partie de
la prophétie de chaque film que nous avons fait,
nous avons en quelque sorte donné quelques réponses, mais
ensuite posé plus de questions,
ce film répond à toutes les questions de
la série et la 3d fait partie de comment  nous
révélons à quoi ressemblent réellement les fantômes dont vous avez
entendu parler dans cinq films,
comment s'est-elle levée si haut que
vous